agreed on a regulatory basis then you
can very quickly pop in another variant
it's winter for the next four months so
so we're already prepared for this
winter we have no reason not to use the
vaccine capacity for new variants
so I think we the uh view would be that
the current vaccines that we have will
give whilst our current one for example
uh both of the bivalence that are being
used here are active against Omicron and
the original what we call the wild type
strain and that breadth of valency
should allow I think
us to manage new variants coming through
most of the ones is Dr waiters said are
actually coming through their their
lineages related to Omicron at the
moment well they have done but um
Omicron turned out to be less bad than
feared we were set for a lockdown last
Christmas until it became established
and the cabinets
the cabinet were not persuaded this was
necessary it turned out that the
existing vaccines were effective against
oricon but the expectation
um at least understand the possibility
they might not be and so this might
happen in the future so just
specifically on that do we have the the
necessary contract signed yet with
moderna for example to survive vaccines
for a new variant were it to be required
so the modern
um agreement I think is not yet
finalized but clearly they've announced
in the media that they are investing
research why isn't it doing finalized
but that's not really a question for for
me to answer I'm afraid I think that
would be for for uh ministers but but
actually the point that you make is are
we working with industry in order to be
prepared and the absolute answer to that
is yes and this is one of the learnings
that I think it's really critical to
share we we have absorbed into the UK
Health Security Agency the vaccine task
force and the work with industry is
continuing through that group so for
example we are working with moderna as
well as with other pharmaceutical
companies one of the um benefits of the
vaccine task force was that close
working relationship meant things could
happen quickly but equally you can
signal ahead where the public health
risk is and work alongside
Pharmaceuticals and that is continuing
that well that is I see behind my
question is to whether we have the
agreement signed in advance in in our
joints inquiry report
we observed a paragraph 394 that the
decision to procure at risk and long in
advance of regulatory approval a broad
portfolio of supplies of potential
vaccines was bold and prescient as was
the commitment to order vaccines in
quantities in excess of what was needed
that came from the from the vaccines
task force the the founding chair of
that task force named Kate Bingham has
been very clear that she thinks that
that
those lessons have been lost in
particular having contracts in place in
advance and it may be a question for the
minister who is waiting to to take your
place Dame Jenny but that is a concern
is it not as if we haven't got the
contracts in place that happened under
Kate Bingham and now we don't so if I I
think I will leave it for the minister
to answer the particular detail on
contract and you'll realize there is
likely to be some commercial sensitivity
around this which is uh so I think
probably I'm not able to go into it in
detail I think the critical point here
is we have all of our vaccines for this
winter are here and we anticipate
scientifically that they will cover the
population going forward not only that
but we have additional supplies ready to
use should we need to reboost or the
current variants from four current
variants but my point is started this is
that the likelihood is that those
vaccines will give the breadth of
protection that would manage a new
variant now if in the unlikely situation
a very new varying came or a different
pathogen which I think is the kind of
test case what is the relationship that
we have in our growing with farmer and
with our scientists and that is that
work of the vaccine task force is
continuing and one of the for the ukhsa
for example we have established a
vaccine development and evaluation
center which is a set up precisely to
have a front door for the pharmaceutical
agency so it's easy for them to come and
work with us when they have new vaccine
candidates going through and they are
already so there is a lot of work there
which I'm very happy to send the detail
to the committee of in after this
meeting so Dean Kate Bingham is wrong
when she says that the UK has lost its
leadership in preparedness when it comes
to vaccines that we've gone back to
business and you as usual that she's
wrong in that assessment issue
um so I I think she perhaps isn't seeing
I mean I absolutely share Dan binger's
dencate's ambition in this it's exactly
what the UK Health Security Agency wants
to do is one of the most exciting
opportunities in science that's come
from the pandemic she may not be seeing
everything that's happening the vaccine
task force came into the ukhsa on the
1st of October clearly we need the prime
issues to move them across safely so
that the vaccination program continues
and the country can continue going
forward but the work is absolutely
ongoing and I think there will become
evidence as our plans materialize I
think Dr Waite wanted to yeah can I
maybe give the example of how this works
through the spring and summer to get the
bivalent program we have now off the
ground as during the over the spring
summer UK HSA the Departments of Health
the VT the vaccine task force nmhra
worked together to make sure that we
purchased and then planned with NHS
England and how how we were going to
deliver the bivalent program that was
before ba5 our most recent wave was even
a thing let alone be a four so we made a
plan around procuring the ba1 wild type
bivalent vaccine because based on
information from ports and down and from
other places we were confident that we
were procuring a vaccine that would be
effective against future variants
because up until now wild type has
covered all of the variants and still
does there are still wild type
activities against ba5 against BQ and so
on so by the time we had licensed via
mhra the ba1 be a wild type vaccine
nobody else had a bivolent vaccine at
all
by the time the ba45 was licensed and
then rolled out in for example France in
early October we had already vaccinated
4.6 million people against ba1 wild type
combined and those that started with the
oldest age groups so that's a good
example of the process still works we
are still following those examples of
4.6 million people were protected who
otherwise and we've gone on to vaccinate
16 million people since then so it's
it's working well thank you here right
Tracy and before I come on to my
specific questions Jenny um Dr Wade just
in a follow-up to a question to Rebecca
Lomb Bailey about inequalities and
uptake discovered from my own case load
at the time that people with learning
disabilities have quite many have quite
a significant severe and debilitating
needle phobia if I just wondered if you
could just update the committee on
progress around a nasal spray
alternative to for the covid vaccine yes
I'm aware that there are nasal spray
vaccines in clinical trials but I think
it's important to keep to sort of remain
circumspects about those a lot of
products that are in clinical trials do
not get to phase two to phase three or
indeed get to Market so I don't want to
put too much hope or expectation on
those being delivered quickly it is both
the mechanism of delivery that is
important so nasal vaccines are
absolutely more acceptable to children
as well as a large number of adults who
are who are needle phobic but we need to
make sure that this is an effective way
of delivering the vaccine we're not at
that stage yet but it's not just for
covid I would say it's quite a promising
area of delivery for a range of vaccines
that currently deliver by needles thank
you
um news relating to avian flu is
featuring prominently at the moment and
while it's clear that the risk that
bourbon food places for humans is very
low it is there and presumably change
and increase so with that in mind what
steps are being taken to deal with
enabling Alien Blue crossover to humans
so that is part of our comprehensive
biosecurity planning routinely I think
what is particularly challenging this
year for a number of reasons is that I
think this is the first year where
actually normally we'd see a seasonal
variation and and so you would have wild
birds not infected actually we're not
seeing that so through this last year
they have retained an infectivity if you
like and so since just since the first
of October 22 this year in that time
we've had 111 infected premises and
significant numbers of wild birds
reported and affected as well so it
feels like a a slight scale change and
obviously that requires us not only to
maintain our current risk alertness but
actually to review more detail the the
current pathogen is an h5n1 and one of
the issues there is the avian pathogen
h5n1 is we actually don't have as much
detailed knowledge as we would like to
know about that it appears to be a
relatively low risk if you like from a
human perspective but we have absolutely
recognized that we need to understand
more and in fact a new risk assessment
was done last week and I know Dr Waite
is on that group working with Academia
and with others to ensure and with apha
to ensure that each of those different
concerns around risk of transmission
particularly looking at the structural
biology so whether you can see whether
antivirus that we have for example would
work but while that is ongoing we
continue to work with the apha we put
zones around it's it's their lead but we
support the work they're identifying
individuals who could potentially become
at risk so obviously poultry workers
understanding whether on an individual
basis whether they've been wearing
appropriate PPE and then advising on
antivirals I mean there are some
challenges because of the numbers here
it takes a lot of time from our local
Health protection teams increasingly and
also the population themselves of people
who owners are are often
um
not English speakers they'll become used
to actually translating and getting risk
communication right for that group can
be quite tricky so sorry is there a
vaccine in place to deal with an
outbreak of um
they're dealt with with prophylactic
antibiotics I mean there have been there
are I might also just say of course
there is an international surveillance
program as well which we're adopt into
and one of our concerns is probably uh
more to do with increasing Rising cases
of of two or three uh avian flues which
have transmitted to humans in China
currently we have only had one
transmission here last Christmas in a
particularly
a particular case where the individual
was literally living with poultry so
there usually has to be very very close
association between the uh the poultry
and the human and so at the moment our
focus is on ensuring that we prevent any
illness developing and we prevent any
risk of onward transmission
there's a huge public interest obviously
other subject so we've got Karen Monahan
and Rachel maskell we're going to
conclude this session at 11 so brevity
on all sides would be much appreciated
Carol
in team Journey I've got four very quick
questions so hopefully I can keep to
time and then possibly a supplementary
on this and first of all what is UK
hse's budget
it will it will it will vary we had a
one-year settlement and so actually our
budget going forward is uh is in
discussion at the moment
um clearly we were born in the middle of
a pandemic to support the management of
a pandemic and that's a very unusual set
of circumstances I thought that should
be a straightforward answer
so what what was last year's budget then
so a budget well the budget going back
of course I've inherited predecessor
organizations as well you're definitely
a politicians
um so so the the budget is uh 2.4
billion but um I might say that we that
is part of that is not but I'm sorry I'm
not trying to avoid the question we as a
health family manage the covid element
across the areas which are most required
so um given that you cannot predict what
the pandemics are doing if I give an
example lateral flow test you allocate a
budget against them but then they're
used by other parts of the system and
and they have been underused equally we
have stepped down the uh on-site testing
stations because we're using natural
flows and sending tests out directly to
individuals ahead of time so we've done
that very efficiently and created and
understand which then goes back into
colleagues in Department of Health and
managing other covert pressures so
assuming we're in a kind of steady state
at the moment
2.4 billion is kind of a
it's an estimate
so that is the covered budget plus the
UK which includes the UK Health Security
Agency component I mean I think as we go
forward and part of the discussions at
the moment is to do with what the UK
Health Security Agency which effectively
is the National Health Protection Agency
is the right non-covered business as
usual studies to do all of the things
which we've described which to ensure we
stand up but of course for a number of
reasons you said we're doing empox with
responding we're supporting Asylum
Seekers we are supporting work in in
Ukraine we're doing all sorts of things
on a regular basis so I think the
importance is this is a very unusual
year as was last year because of the
covid pandemic
thank you I thought that that was only
question one I thought that would be
really quick
so how much of the your budget at the
moment is for disease surveillance
that's a very difficult question to
answer and I'm happy to try and provide
some separate
um estimates of that and the reason I
say it is because some of the learning
from the pandemic is about as I think
others have said earlier about ensuring
data linkage so when we think about
surveillance there is things like the
community infection survey here which
the the commissioner which has come
through the UK Health Security Agency
but it also includes things like work
with on global international health so
we're working with the development of
the Berlin herbal International passage
and surveillance Network and
fundamentally it includes a provision
which was in our budget to improve the
digital technology and infrastructure
which is absolutely critical to ensure
that some of the new systems we have so
things like our second generation
surveillance system meeting it's
somebody a lamp so uh sorry watch so
again lab tests for respiratory
infection in hospitals and other
infectious disease come through and we
routinely survey so again sorry that's
not a straightforward answer but it's
coming from technology it's coming from
International work and a number of other
areas I think it might be useful if you
could write to the committee with had
some sort of figures if if you could do
that the next question should be easier
and what is a UK HSS head count
to at the peak of the combined
organizations was actually around
eighteen thousand we all know it's I
think just around six thousand seven
hundred and it's around six and a half
thousand full-time equivalent that is
not a stable Workforce at the moment so
when the organization came into being it
was only 30 substantive post and that
reflects the difficult period what we're
doing now is downsizing in some and
increasing substantively in others with
variation in size in different places
okay and um
how many of those individuals are
working on disease surveillance
I can I I will include that if you want
so maybe a different question then
you've
not quite been able to answer questions
on budget
um head count you've given us some idea
maybe the question then is is the budget
and there's a heads count enough
for
um Horizon scanning the situation we
have just now in terms of global threats
so I think it is easier if I come back
and I'm not wishing to detract from the
question but what I'm trying to say is
the same individuals for example who
will be evaluating monkeypox vaccine
again we put out a publication last week
we'll also be using those skills to
evaluate against new variants the same
people who are using Building Technology
are building different systems to link
us into Hospital data on every other
infectious disease so am I on
antimicrobial resistance so I'm very if
if it's just covered we would have to
proportionize it and I'm happy to come
back with not just profit but generally
you know looking for what is the next
threat
um so what you're seeing is a lot of
people are multitasking within in actual
fact if you look and this is one of the
difficult things to explain as a health
Security Agency if you you can't divide
a program budget off very easily what
you need is an infrastructure of digital
infrastructure you need animal who can
turn to different diseases you need
infectious disease experts on different
topics but they will also be the
individuals who are leading the response
to an incident management team so if
there's an outbreak you pull them in so
if you start dismantling one bit often
the other bits don't work which is why
giving an individual figure is probably
not a representative really of the
different inputs to that section they
need to work together thank you
and then the personification of brevity
is Rachel Masco from the health Team
thank you and good morning
um the rapid containment of the virus is
absolutely crucial in containing uh the
disease so turning to track and traits
clearly having a national system there
was inefficiencies within that whereas
locally there is better data if it's
more responsive and people knew their
own community so what would you do
differently looking forward around
containment and tracking traits
um so what I'll speak actually as an ex
director of Public Health and I I liaise
very often with uh directly with
director of Public Health and have and
understand this from both sides
um I think when test and Trace has set
up it was set up a time when actually
local systems could not have coped
because of the scale that was required
um nevertheless those local systems
continue to work as do the health
protection teams the ukhsa health
protection teams and I think there is
strong recognition that as we go forward
and in fact what we are doing now is to
take the learning from both of those and
put them together in a while in a way
which works routinely proportionately
but then is scalable efficiently and
effectively when you get something as
significant as a pandemic to some extent
we have tested it actually with the mpox
outbreak because where you get a
significant Regional or national
infection obviously not as as
problematic as the pandemic was for the
whole population
uh but we've tried that so one of the
examples I give is we now have a single
service center for contact tracing and
we can work with directors of Public
Health to either take calls centrally or
move them over and we did actually
evaluate the work which uh local teams
have done a national and what it shows
broadly is that for some families
particularly exactly as you say a local
director will know their communities for
those ones where they're hard to reach
they would be able to reach them where
central systems couldn't however for
overall for efficiency actually the
central system with large numbers was
more efficient so it's it's kind of
horses for courses in what you're trying
to do the critical point is working
together is the important one and we
have a piece of work which ukhsa myself
co-chairing with Jim McManus from
Association of directs and public health
but at the future of Health protection
system to really clarify post pandemic
the roles and responsibilities of each
bit so that when we go into these urgent
mode we automatically click into the
right path you know the right
streamlined approach and then we can
hand things backwards and forwards as as
appropriate to manage the risk
okay thank you very much
we've covered a huge amount of ground
Dave Jenny Harris Dr Thomas weight thank
you very much change the panels please
moving on to to panel three this
Marathon session we have the first time
before any part of the Health and Social
care committee Neil O'Brien MP who's the
minister for Primary Care and Public
Health at the Department of Health and
Social care of course Michelle Dyson
director General adult social Care at
the department and Clara Swinson
director General Global Health also at
the department welcome sorry to keep you
waiting but I'm sure you enjoyed hearing
that evidence Minister nice to see you
um how much of your time
is taken up think other than preparing
for today's session how much time how
much of your time is taken at thinking
about
working on covid
um so uh president said um great
pleasure to be in front of my former
committee uh once again and um thank you
for having us I mean this just
emphasized this piece of work is
something we regard as hugely important
it was uh good that we were able to
support the overwhelming majority of the
recommendations in your report which is
incredibly useful we're obviously also
supporting the covert public inquiry
which is uh in a very forensic way going
through all these questions as well
um and to come to come to your question
I am not the minister for um uh for aksa
uh that is my uh colleagues Maria
Caufield I am responsible for Primary
Care and for
overhead side of Public Health but
nonetheless
the impact of the
pandemic on the public health and on
Primary Care was enormous and is
something that I have spent a decent
amount of time thinking about and
following not just as part of preparing
for this committee but more generally
following
work on how we make sure that we are
better prepared for any future pandemic
yeah thank you and and you're right and
the government did respond or with
acceptance or partial acceptance so
pretty much all of the recommendations I
report I think with with to the
exclusion of the stuff around the
involvement of the army where they
didn't accept our recommendations in in
the way that they were put but one of
the things that said in the response is
that the government tends to set up a
catastrophic emergency program to focus
on 10 risks which may give rise to whole
system emergencies including pandemics
could you tell us about catastrophic
emergencies program yeah so there's
there's quite a lot of different ways
that we have changed our whole approach
to pandemics
um I think the first thing to say is
that there's a change of fundamental
approach so uh we're going to have a
what we call a kind of pathogen agnostic
approach to planning for pandemics
previously our criticism has been made
by those people was that the focus was
on pandemic flu which was identified as
the kind of number one risk and now our
approach is about thinking about a much
wider range of pathogens with different
disease characteristics and scenarios of
course I think with covid was the
asymptomatic transmission was the thing
that everyone will always come back to
and that sort of capabilities based
approach involves thinking about all the
different tools we've got the
Diagnostics the surveillance the
scientific advice the clinical
countermeasures the Border controls the
legislation all those different tools
that we had to to deploy during this
pandemic the other second bit of this
sort of change of approach is the change
of fundamental structures obviously so
the splitting of phe the creation of
aksa in October last year and within
aksa the center for pandemic
preparedness within it is effectively a
cell that is like the heart of a kind of
Global Network that involves thinking
about pandemic preparedness
um but the third thing I say about our
change of approach is a huge massive
Improvement in surveillance and
international coordination on it
um so the UK was a founding member of
the international pathogen surveillance
Network which is there to coordinate
International detection of uh pathogens
and also data sharing on emerging
threats and we also found a member of
The g7's 100 days Mission which is there
to coordinate work on kind of
Diagnostics vaccines and therapies
specifically
a sort of fourth thing that was
different about how how we would do
things differently now is there is this
sort of constant improvement work that
goes on within aksa which involves both
regular exercises at different scales
and also learning from that day-to-day
response and um the kind of day-to-day
activity of managing local outbreaks and
particular
challenges and then the fifth and final
way we've changed our approach and we've
touched a bit on this in the session
already is
um is capacity building really so
thinking about uh most straightforward
way you know through real reviewing our
requirements for critical
countermeasures and things like PPE
we have already talked in this session a
bit about the agreement with moderna for
UK development and production of new
vaccines to ensure resilience and NHS
supply chain and dhscl also working with
PPE manufacturers to make sure that we
have resilience of Supply chains which
was such an issue at the start of the
pandemic all over the world
are now about 75 of The ffp3 Masks are
used by the NHS and social care are now
made in the UK are from approximately
zero percent of the start of the
pandemic so there is an overall
um changeover approach to the way we
would manage pandemics
um and I if I can bring in chloro I'm
not gonna I'm just gonna just gonna
Focus actually so obviously you you sat
there and you heard uh Dame Jenny give
you a nice pass on moderna so I'm just
going to let my fellow chair uh simple
question
um has it been signed to this um yeah so
we agreed the heads of terms of the
agreement in June and both at their
desire and also our desire that is uh
the great majority of the agreement we
all wanted to resolve all the main
issues of principle in that initial
agreement and so as it were the Great
majority of the negotiation is done the
reasons illustrate the problem that um
democate is described so Dame Kate's
time in running the vaccine task force
went from May to December 2020 just over
six months
since you agreed the heads of agreement
that accounts for would now really in
December nearly the whole time that Dame
Kate performed her Miracles when she was
in office doesn't it show that what she
says is true that you drop the ball that
you agreed something nearly six months
ago and you haven't been able to assign
anything beyond heads of terms I I don't
agree with that as much as I have a huge
respect for what was achieved so quickly
by the vaccine's task force and on this
agreement which is a very long-term uh
agreement it's a piece of industrial
strategy broadly speaking a piece of
kind of resilience
um architecture we have let's be clear
agreed a lot of this we agreed that
construction of this facility will start
next year we have agreed that vaccine
Manufacturing in the UK will start in
2025 so the great majority of this is
agreed but because of the open-ended
nature of it and the ability to flex
we're not just buying one thing here
we're buying a capability to buy
respiratory
vaccines against respiratory viruses of
various kinds because we are buying a
very flexible tool that is a
fundamentally complicated negotiation I
have been across some of the more recent
rounds of exactly how we land that and
we are extremely close uh uh to
finalizing the remaining detail but just
to reassure you uh when would you say
you haven't signed this thing yet you've
just got some sort of vague agreement in
principle that is not the case we have
agreed the substantive bulk of all that
needs to be agreed and we are now
chasing down the detail will be a better
characterization of where we are at with
it and the reason that takes a few
months and not because anybody's dropped
the ball it's because if I was a if I
was them as I was company I was opening
into I deliberately highly flexible and
quite open-ended long-term agreement
with the government to provide a
capability not just a product I would
also be going quite for instantly with
my lawyers through the detail of it
any further now but the committee might
want to take this forward all I would
say is that the evidence that the joint
inquiry took during the pandemic was
that if we hadn't had signed legally
binding contracts we wouldn't have got
the supplies when the balloon went up
lots of other jurisdictions wanted them
absolutely existence of those signed
contracts was crucial but the only thing
I'd say is there's a slight difference
between that Global scramble to secure
things which also happened on PP as well
as you as you know and this which is a
piece of something which we have
discussed before and it leads on
actually from John Bell's work back in
2016 and 2017. this is a piece of
industrial strategy it's a piece of
resilience architecture and it's not
just like have you signed a contractor
in order to buy a thing this is to get
and create a permanent new capability
for the UK
thank you
um in our joint report a there was
questions about the the
um setup of sage and how Sage operated
and was made and and one of the
statements we made was the government's
Sage should facilitate strong external
and structured challenge to Scientific
advice including from experts in
countries around the world on a wider
range of disciplines so if I could ask
Minister have there been any reforms
made to see June if so what are they
so I think that that is what Sage does
do so Sage Drew on something like 240
different participants during the
pandemic uh response and of course it's
not the only Advisory Group we've got
we've also got nerve tag and jessevi and
they drew on a very very wide pool of
expertise from very very many
disciplines they build on top of the
work that we've got from ministers with
respect this was one of the findings of
her inquiry was that it was that it's
certainly at the start of the pandemic
it was a very narrow range of
disciplines that were involved and that
International experts were not involved
in that so so that was one of the issues
at the start of the pandemic so I I
touched on and I will come back to you
in a second this point about the
international
connections but I do want to slightly
push back on this idea that Sage is some
sort of Haven of group think and
like-minded individuals who've all got
the same expertise but it's just not the
case we as a government have accessed
all these different advisor groups
including Sage which is itself highly
diverse intellectually and terms of
people's expertise we also have the CMOS
you've heard from Deputy CMOS Alexa team
users we've got Girl science but
ministers have access to advice from
people with a very broad range of views
in a very of context and they're during
the pandemic they liberally went out and
took the views of all kinds of people
from Minority positions Richard Fairman
said that science is not a democracy and
that's a very important thing to always
grasp
and I think ministers were challenging
of the evidence that was put to them we
talked a bit earlier in this session
about the discussion around Omicron or
whether it be need to be another
lockdown that's another example of where
ministers in the cabinet collectively um
I did stress test the data very hard and
what was emerging but I think I think
that it is sometimes overdone is to
forget the sense of the fog of war that
was happening for this novel pathogen
and the uncertain evidence I think there
was actually a huge range of use about
what was going on during Sage during the
critical NZ during the critical early
stages of the pandemic we have of course
trying to always try to improve these
things hence the connections into that
International
pathogen surveillance Network to make
sure we're not insular that we see
everything happening all over the world
that's Central the connections into the
G7 and that Center for parandemic
preparedness that I mentioned earlier on
which is although it's a just a unit
within a decent size unit is the center
of a kind of space web of our
connections for the rest of the world to
make sure that we are always further
diversifying our sources of evidence and
that we're seeing everything that we
possibly can across the whole world
it's like so I think you've half
answered it in that you there are
greater International connections it was
one of our criticisms and I'm not sure
you've answered the first bit but we'll
move on um but the Evian bird flu is a
current concern and what role has Sage
played in
um in advising government and what sort
of advice have you received from Sage on
this I I I'll have to ask Clara on this
one I'm afraid maybe beyond what you've
already heard from Deputy CMA
good morning
um so it's while it's an animal
um uh LED it's a Deborah lead Sage
hasn't been set up I don't think for
avian flu but in terms of the animal and
plant health agency all of the
um
uh both surveillance which AXA do do a
lot of both for
um the birds themselves genetic testing
and surveillance of Health uh poultry
workers and so on that is
um that is based on their advice and
then it would be a death lead in their
agency in terms of the management of the
apron fluid outbreaks if if we saw any
crossover what what do you envisage
sages role would be in that
so um obviously it will depend on the
scale but first of all if there was in
terms of the threat to human health that
would go to nerve tag the new emerging
respiratory viruses threats group as in
fact um
coronavirus did
and then if Sage was stood up if the
government decides to set that up for
any emergency chaired by the government
at Chief Scientific Advisor if that was
necessary and how quickly do you reckon
that would take that could be done I
mean Sage can be set up in a matter of
hours
thank you thank you good okay Chris
thank you uh Minister uh obviously if we
impose a lockdown there's going to be
it's going to protect us from the the
virus and the disease but also it's
going to have wider impacts on schools
uh wider Healthcare and the economy one
of the concerns during not not with the
first lockdown we appreciate why that
was in that way but with the second and
third lockdown uh that wasn't a
published impact assessment on those
other areas would the government
reconsider the position of not
publishing one of those impacts because
I think whether it's people around the
country and certainly members of voting
or making decisions in this area we
should be better informed
so the first two things I say are just
this piece of reinsurance is that I
don't see any future in which we are
doing further lockdowns there's no
particular reason to think that there
would be any such thing ever happened
again but to answer your question
directly of course we want to always
improve
the information that is available to uh
to members of this house and to the
government I think we would strain and
continue if we ever found ourselves in
anything even vaguely similar again to
make sure we had
um a full uh you know account of as much
as
everything as one could give to the
public lots of things are not Noble but
um we would make every effort to make
sure we would be good thank you
thank you Chris thank you chair
um thank you Minister Melissa um can I
just ask a couple of quick questions uh
we heard earlier that some of the
preventative measures for the impending
sort of triple threat of diseases over
the winter what we could do is maybe you
know the washing the hands the wear and
masks all of that stuff can I just
clarify have any masks been burned
I'm not aware of my sweet but I can ask
Chloe I mean there's a there's a there
is a deliberate sort of PPE stockpile of
the things that we need so we can search
capability I don't know it must have
been burnt yeah I mean certainly we have
a large amount of PPE the Nao has looked
at this extensively in terms of where it
is Surplus to our requirements there's a
range of things donating and working out
on uh length of time and so on
um but if you want to know more detail
on Mars specifically because there's a
range of things when the PPA stockpile
we can get back to you on that that
would be brilliant thank you and um and
and just on that I mean the NHS was
publishing weekly consumption data
during the pandemic which I think
important and important going forward if
we are to face another pandemic I just
wondered how did it
um how did we come to buy five times as
much PP as we needed so I think on both
PPE and also testing capacity
uh there is a a choice a big choice
about what level of resilience you want
and how much you are prepared to have
that and so for example on testing which
we're discussing earlier in this session
we have made a conscious choice to have
excess testing capacity we will have the
ability to scale testing far beyond the
levels that we currently needed at and
we are therefore making sure that we do
lots of things to make sure that those
people are not simply standing around
that they're doing other useful things
but to be clear we are paying a price
taxpayers of playing a price for us to
have that capability to scale very very
rapidly which I think many members of
this committee would want us to have so
generally resilience comes at a price
and the same thing is true in PPE at the
start of the pandemic all of us as
members were frantically trying to get
everything that we could possibly happen
have to happen to get more PPE into the
system we now want to make sure we're
not back in that situation again and
that involves two things involves both
having some degree of stockpile one
could debate the details of how big the
stockpile should be and the second part
of that is having a resilient UK supply
chain so we don't end up back in the
situation we were in when it was a
global scramble at the same time so it
was it was deliberate to buy five times
I don't know I could tell you it was
deliberated by a particular
multiple of of quotes what is needed and
it's often difficult to work out exactly
what will be needed you it was certainly
a decision in both these cases to have
enough capacity to be able to surgeon to
meet the need if it increases and there
is always a price to pay for having
those kind of resiliences
here and my last question
um chair is is it just possible
um because as we're looking at Lessons
Learned and going back to our joint
committee session there's still some
missing information so I'm just
wondering if it's possible to get a
breakdown of uh the pp that was provided
from each Company please I mean if you
could just provide that to the
Committees later on that would be useful
please we'll undertake you to get you
whatever we can brilliant thank you
James Morris
I just wanted to turn to social care
because I think it's fair to say that
particularly the beginning of the
pandemic it was there was a sense that
decisions were being taken
um uh about social care which actually
had a devastating impact on the social
care system at that time and caused lots
of uh lots of issues and I'm just
wondering in terms of thinking about
responding to future pandemics or in
terms of planning how do we make sure
that the social care sector doesn't feel
that it's being done too that it's part
of the prepare preparedness and planning
for a future pandemic it's a hugely
important question that we thought about
so I would say that the relationship
between
dhsc and the social care sector has been
completely transformed by the pandemic
and the things that we've done
during it and there are several headings
I would group that under the first is
about data and knowing what is going on
so during it we created the capacity
tracker we just had thousand times more
information than we used to about what
is going on in the sector we also
legislated last year to give the CQC the
inspection power over local Authority
social care functions and that will give
us from next year even more data about
what is going on in the data that sounds
all good stuff on the specific point
which is do you think that the
specifically to the minister do you
think that our social care system is
going to be adequately funded in the
future to be able to cope with
another pandemic and the issues that
that come along with it
um because there is an argument that the
reason the social care system was put
under so much pressure as a in the first
wave of the pandemic was that it was in
a very weakened state to start with and
successive governments have not funded
social care adequately so there is a
kind of important point about its
resilience and its its capacity to
respond uh the record increase in
funding that was announced in the Autumn
statement I think it's absolutely right
and I agree with the spirit of your
question so we're going to put in
another 2.4 up to another 2.4 billion
next year and then up to 4.8 billion the
year after and that is to address
exactly the points that you are raising
to increase the capacity uh in the
sector both for day-to-day purposes and
also to have that kind of Greater
resilience but just to to reassure you
on the scale of the change I mean
everything has changed the structures in
the department are different we have a
DG in the department when we didn't
before we have a chief nurse for adult
social care
Deborah sturdy who was not there before
we have a completely different agenda on
it and much more active agenda we had
the white paper on adult social care so
that Workforce and qualifications Dayton
the creation of digital care records
which will let you have a much better
sense of how people are flowing around
the system and also cut a load of
bureaucracy and save people a lot of
time who work in Social care we've had
the integration like paper and again
this huge push that we have going on
about the greater integration of NHS
functions with local Authority functions
so once upon a time they were quite
poorly integrated to are you confident
maybe I don't know Michelle or anybody
else are you confident that in a future
situation with a future pandemic that
um that there are there is now a
structure and a process whereby
decisions that may be taken about social
care
um will be taken in conjunction with the
social care sector and will reflect
their concerns and we won't get into a
situation that we've gotten in the first
the pandemic when all kinds of decisions
were making which had quite devastating
unintended consequences and yes I I am
confident that we have both the money
and the better connections to the sector
to deal with future pandemics and I
wonder if I could bring in Michelle just
to talk a bit about her connections
which I could have extensive in this
because there are
I want to bring in Paula Hamilton he's
got a very specific question relating to
those record sums for social care
announcing the Autumn statement Paulette
did you want to put your question 20
Oh I thought mine was 20 yes okay
sorry I thought it was about the
Holiness about them
Health inequalities okay
um
fine fine yes
um you you ask you ask your question
Paula the the question was just going to
be about yes we understand what you're
saying about record sums but of course
that does rely on local authorities
choosing to go to the five percent the
questions does hang rather as to what if
they don't
choose to do that I must concern you so
just because some of the money is just
straightforwardly granted into social
care so we have the new new money
additional new money from the treasury
going directly into the better care fund
uh we have new additional uh money going
to the adult social Care Grants we then
also have the social care ground on top
of that and yes there is also
possibility is about the council tax
flexibility but just to reassure you
there are also new direct grants from
central government into social care
about which there's no ambiguity or
choice of going straight into social
care yeah but yes there is you know
localism those are all for local
authorities okay right so editing out
the last exchange question uh from
Paulette Hamilton unhealthy inequalities
of course right brilliant
um thank you Minister um the data from
the ons shows that the death rates
during cold during the covid-19 pound
endemic was disproportionately higher
for black and Asian ethnic minority
groups can I ask why did it take so long
to understand the ethnic disparities and
secondly
um I've had this thing about
um the information being included on
death certificates which still hasn't
happened
um as standard and finally I've done it
all together what is the department I'm
doing to reduce Health disparities and
will these be outlined in the upcoming
white paper
so several crucial questions there in
terms of the importance of this I
absolutely agree with my own
constituency on the edge of Leicester uh
majority minority ethnic City it was
something I was personally worried about
as a constituency right from the start
because I have a lot of large
multi-household
homes in my constituency and I think In
fairness to the system
very quickly in the pandemic there was
great emphasis as soon as we had proper
data proper testing you could actually
link up to
give some sense of what was happening
with
hospitalization and fatality rates we I
remember very early on we started to see
that data about the the disparities
they're very concerning disparities in
the effect of the pandemic on different
uh minority ethnic groups and so there's
a huge amount of work now going on to
try and
learn from that and to narrow some of
those Health inequalities
overall in terms of our kind of overall
framework for thinking about this as you
know we've got the goals to increase
healthy life expectancy and narrow the
gaps in healthier life expectancy
between the best and most areas we also
have the agreement across the NHS to use
as a framework for doing that the
so-called core 20 plus five framework
which is about the 20 most deprived plus
a series of ethnic minority groups and
then five major conditions
to focus on the drive Health disparities
and then in the Health and Social Care
Act we passed the other year we put the
duty on icbs to pay due regard to health
disparities
and then so as well as the structural
changes so we also had Kimmy bednock's
four reports on covid and minority
groups which then LED on to the
inclusive Britain action plan in March
which led all to things like the
maternity disparities task force so
there's a sort of change of framework
and then there's also a bunch of
specific actions so we are for example
we talked earlier in this session about
driving vaccine take-up where it is
lower and to add to what the dcmo said
you know we have seminars with face
leaders we deliberately choose
vaccination centers in places of worship
so we get to places both in our National
Communications and our choice of local
advertising and targeted advertising we
have made efforts to drive up
vaccination we've even used things like
vaccination buses and taxis and direct
door-to-door knocking some of which I
saw a bit in my own constituency so
we're doing lots of things to drive up
our vaccine take up particularly in the
groups where it's low
in terms of our work on the elective
recovery and busting the backlog from
the pandemic we have pressed all trusts
to have a plan in place to identify
disparities in that elective recovery
and deal with them
in terms of things like blood donations
which is long-standing issues
we have a whole campaign going on at the
moment particularly for black blood
donors called not family but blood and
we've done things like tie-ups around
the recent wakanda forever movie which
has driven a lot of extra black blood
donation we've also done legal changes
things like changes to the selection
criteria which previously were ruling
out people from donating blood if
they've been to particular countries
we've taken a better approach to that
and of course we've created the office
for health Improvement and disparities
which launched in October and that
drives then a huge amount of other work
that tackles the causes of Health
disparities for example the 900 million
that we are investing additionally into
the drug strategy that was launched last
year that takes us up to investing three
billion into drug treatment over the
next three years which will hugely
increase the availability of treatment
give us something like another 55 000
extra places in drug treatment we're
doing things like the start for Life
program which is again tackling the
first 75 authorities that are part of
that program can I um our deliberately
targeted to be the most deprived the
point was the disparities on the um
around the death data will that be
included under death certificate anytime
soon because that was part of the issues
why we struggled at first to find out
what what the proportions of the
different groups were because it wasn't
there so I will undertake to go away and
pump faster anything that needs to be
bumped faster on that particular front
I've seen lots of I've been following
lots of the data on uh disparities in
ethnic minority
hospitalization and death rates from the
um pandemic and we now have a
particularly because of chemists for
reports a much better understanding of
the things that then drove there but if
there is anything more we can do in
terms of better understanding because I
hear that lots have been done but what
I'd like to see is what has been the
results from all this scattered work
that has been done and at the moment I'm
not hearing that but thank you for that
Minister thank you thank you thank you
minister so then we're just going to
wrap up now with a little one from Aaron
Bell and from retro math school starting
with Aaron thanks thanks Chad thank you
Minister
um just continuing with health
inequalities and disparities the other
thing we picked up of course was
disparities within the workforce and
particularly the fit of PPE to NHS and
social care stuff
you the government has said that they've
made more masks available are there
still disparities in the Pass rates for
those masks
um and how widespread is the
availability of those Masters do people
know how they can get hold of them if
they need them well it said yes so uh as
part of that effort that I described
earlier on to build up a more resilient
UK supply chain one of the things that's
given us the ability to do is to have a
wider variety of masks and I I think
we've gone up from something like eight
types of masks to 16 broadly speaking
and on top of that we also provided a
lot of additional fits testing so
something like 300 000 extra fit tests
so that more people are able to get a
truly well-fitting mask I think the
success rate overall for fit testing has
has gone up a bit from memory something
like 70 to 85 but I don't think it is
the case that there are ethnic
disparities in fit
now
if that's wrong please do do jump in uh
partly because we have been working to
provide a greater range of masks so that
everyone can get the PV they need but in
the response the government said
carrying past rate of over 80 on the
range of masks currently available if
you were able to send to the committee
the details of each mask in the past
rate that might be helpful
um I'll get you whatever we can get you
on thank you and on um people with
learning disabilities which my colleague
Tracy Crouch referred to earlier uh have
we been able to improve Communications
to improve vaccine uptake amongst people
with learning difficulties uh yes you're
sorry I'm so sorry I didn't mention this
before yes dcmo has been again going and
doing seminars on this point and there's
been a parallel process to the one that
I described on ethnic disparities in
vaccine take up for the learning
disabled as well with similar things
happening in it so apologies for not
mentioning that before and then do we
have any figures on on the effectiveness
of that work uh I we will certainly have
figures on on take-up rates which I'm
afraid will continue to lag as there is
a problem that we are trying to solve
there but I will try and get you in
account of the efficacy of what we've
been doing thank you minister
I think Rachel has a good question ever
showed thank you Minister on evershield
um it's conditionally improved by the
mhra and yet the immunosuppressed people
remain unvaccinated isolated and at risk
that your precessor said that they hope
to have a nice assessment prior to April
2023 and I have said that it could be
faster Could you um set out exactly
where things are on ever shells and
protection for the immunosuppressed and
will this also be
um
effective against new variants yeah so
it's a very good question so to answer
it I need to explain a tiny bit of the
framework here so normal processes
everyone knows is that mhra licensed
things are safe for use and effective to
some extent and then nice to work on
cost-benefit economic analysis they
consult widely getting better data on
efficacy and the process takes longer
during the pandemic we had a rapid c19
which is a group of an independent group
of clinicians and scientists that
recommended purchases on an emergency
basis because of the nature of the
pandemic and the pace of what the normal
life's process looks like and they
judged that it was right on an emergency
basis to buy antivirals for treatment
like paxilabid and mole new pyramid and
those things were there was judged with
right to buy on an emergency basis
because they are not very sensitive to
new variants whereas monoclonal antibody
treatments like evershaled are quite
specific to the nature of the spike
protein because of their natural
operation and this issue is not specific
to evershaled and ronaprev which is an
antibody that we were using in NHS last
Autumn has actually been withdrawn from
Clinical policies because it wasn't
effective against Omicron variants and
that group rapid c19 did not recommend
buying every shelled through the
emergency route and it thought there was
insufficient just evidence to justify it
and so they should go through the normal
nice process and when to be clear when
the mhra licensed uh evershell they did
so on the basis of all the clinical
trials data pre-omicron and noted that
it might not be as effective against
newer variants post homicron and the in
vitro tests that do suggest it is in
fact less effective against newer
variants and in fact the USA's FDA and
its Canadian equivalent have written out
to provide this anti-patients using it
to warn them of this and at the moment
nice has been reviewing the
cost-effectiveness of all the medicines
that we use in the NHS to treat covid
their draft recommendation on this is
out for consultation and that draft
suggests that ever shelled is not
recommended for use as a covered
treatment let's be clear there's a
treatment for someone who's got it
rather than as a a
prophylactic
so I totally understand that the
decision not to buy on an emergency
basis but to go through the nice route
is disappointing for some who are at
worse of risk outcomes from covert
there's several things to say about that
the first is that um the success of the
vaccination program has meant that the
requirements for shielding that were
there before are no longer necessary
of course there is still a shared
National effort to uh to behave sensibly
to use maths to where appropriate to not
spread viruses to help those who are
vulnerable and worry about these things
and within that group of people who are
concerned there are smaller number of
people whose immune system does put them
at more risk and we have in enhanced
protections for them free testing more
guidance on managing risk and including
access quick access to those antivirals
that I mentioned that we have bought so
if they do get it the risk is further
reduced because we have those new
technologies that we didn't have at the
start of the
pandemic but of course every Shield was
never going to be uh uh any kind of
protection against other dangerous
respiratory viruses like flu which will
always be out there so we always need to
be helping protect those people uh by
taking those basic steps that we can all
take to protect them and we also
exploring very actively options for
covet antibody testing this winter to
help those people who are worried or who
have the immunosuppression better
understand their risks that's something
we're working on very actively
a very clear explanation Michelle Dyson
Neil O'Brien Clara Swinson thank you
very much thank you includes the third
panel uh Greg Clark and I can have a
slot chairs for our fourth and Final
thank you very much indeed
um and just while we do so I'm delighted
to spot on the screen uh Damon Kate
Bingham
Kate was chair of the vaccines task
force from May to December 2020 she is a
board member of the Francis Crick
Institute and is managing partner at SV
Health investors very grateful for your
patience this has been a session that
has has overrun a bit but we're anxious
to hear from you and of course it's the
the case that don't case work in that
relatively brief period of a little over
uh six or seven months made as the first
country in the world to be able to
administer a vaccine against covid
um don't get perhaps I can kick off with
a question
um you said in an interview uh published
I think today with developed that the UK
seems to have lost its leadership
approach in vaccine r d vaccine
manufacturing and procurement in 2020 we
were clearly World leading but the UK
went back to business as usual so what's
going on
what what's gone wrong is uh
[Music]
expert or leader that's put in place to
coordinate
the activities from everything from
vaccine Innovation scale up landscaping
and figuring out whether new variants
may come from the new potential pandemic
viruses people understand manufacturing
scale at clinical development regulatory
all of that is gone I don't I mean maybe
there's somebody secret out there but
that that is doing that but not as far
as I can see and there's no we've got
the capability in the country but it
can't be done in a vacuum we need to
have an expert leader to to bring that
together to keep us or to try and get us
back into a better position
um you're not talking about a minister
there you're talking about a someone
appointed you just mentioned experience
an expert to to to run this operation
yes I mean whether it it needs to be
someone who understands the space so
that um it probably means somebody from
the outside who has that experience in
industry and it was the first
recommendation we made so when I left
into summer 2020 we gave some very
specific recommendations as to what we
thought should happen and the first that
I'm reading an independent industrial
experience chairman and board should be
established to bring together the
various strands of vaccine activities
that will Define UK as a global leader
in vaccine development and Manufacturing
that's not happened
and why has that not happened do you
have a viewers to that is it because
it's been transferred into the UK Health
Security Agency and it's been
discontinued in the model that you uh
worked in which was a separate uh body
the vaccine starts Force
I mean to begin with I thought it was
lack of experience of officials since we
don't have a lot of people within
Whitehall that understand
um vaccines relationships with industry
all of that but actually I'm beginning
to think this is actually deliberate
government policy just not to not to
invest and not to support the sector
because it it I cannot explain why we
haven't appointed somebody that can
actually bring all this together because
we've got the capabilities and yet
systematically things are being
dismantled that we put in place
I mean our joint committee's reports
um was very clear that of all of the
aspects of the response to the pandemic
the creation of the vaccines task force
and its work yours but with a uh you led
a team of people who gave extraordinary
Public Service coming from outside
government was one of the the beacons of
success
um
have you had any conversations with
anyone in government since as to why
they thought such a successful model
should be abolished
well I mean three office of Life
Sciences as the announcement that was
out on Monday is to create four missions
uh specifically to advance you know
cancer dementia and so on and that has
been uh apparently modeled on vaccine
task force and yes I have been talking
to them about how to bring that
urgency and goal setting and delivery to
those missions but no I've not had a
discussion about why why the decision
has been taken not to appoint anybody
with this sort of experience to bring
together the activities and the
capabilities that we have in the UK nor
have I had a discussion with anybody
about
um why things that we did put in place
are now being dismantled do you have an
example of things that you put in place
that are being dismantled
so we make that was um this is the
vaccine manufacturing and Innovation uh
um Center and we scaled it up uh through
with Oxford biomedical to help
massively increase the manufacturing
capability in that case of the Oxford
vaccine and that was sold to catalent uh
earlier this year catalent has now
announced their mothballing any
expenditure into vmic until 2024 at the
earliest so uh far from uh uh supporting
and investing in manufacturing onshore
it's
sold and and mothballed so that's the
example of catalent uh Cobra was bought
by Charles River they were a key part of
the early scale up for the vaccine
manufacturing and getting first into the
clinical trials and then actually
ultimately in the boat manufacture that
manufacturing has been transferred and
is being transferred to the US
um the the bulk manufacturing for
antibodies we had interest from industry
to partner with government to build up
that scale I mean I noticed the last
conversation was about every child I
just read with the comments that were
being made But there again none of that
has been taken forward the NHS registry
I am a member of it and I've had two
emails telling me it's closing down I
tweeted it I said I think that's a
pretty dumb decision uh and then uh
Robert generic managed to reverse that
but only after substantial Goodwill has
been lost so 550 550 000 people who
thought they were actually trying to
help the clinical development in the
country has been repeatedly told you're
not helping you've got to start again
and and join a different registry so I'm
baffled as to the decisions that are
being made uh you pointed out in your
last comment
um about why was the moderna contract
not signed goodness knows it does not
take six months to go from a heads of
terms to a binding contract
you heard what I said to uh to the
minister on that point that I seem to
recall that you regarded as crucial that
we had signed contracts that we could
insist on otherwise we wouldn't have got
the supplies that we did that that made
such an impact here is that is that a
very reflection
I mean
it worked legal contracts you've got to
have binding legal contracts to ensure
delivery so I mean I I absolutely
welcome uh the concept of a big
relationship with moderna to provide and
bring both r d and Manufacturing to the
UK so that I'm very positive about
haven't seen it happen I haven't seen or
nor do I know whether or not the same
offer was made to apply to Beyond Tech
with whom we have a close relationship
and they've clearly delivered for the UK
so it just seems odd that that those you
know that nothing has yet been signed
and it also seems odd to me that there
is a singular focus on mRNA as opposed
to maintaining a broader capability
across different vaccine formats I mean
one of the key uh lessons in our joint
inquiries report was that we had to be
better at preparedness for future
pandemics of whatever type they were
um
does the devastating assessment of what
you've what you see does that lead you
to lose confidence in our ability to to
respond adequately to Future pandemics
I mean I don't think we are in a in a
much better place to deal with a new
pandemic I think we're marginally better
I think there's there's a sense in the
UK that um
I mean first of all we're quite Pro
vaccination that's good uh we merely did
have a positive reputation to other
countries around the world clearly did
see us as doing a good job and we do
have some greater vaccine manufacturing
capability through the work that we did
in terms of scaling up some of the
existing suppliers so the contract
development manufacturing organizations
and as I said I think the concept of the
moderna contract is great and we've
invested in skills to support
biomanufacturing
expertise so all of that I think is
really positive but uh without the
leadership without uh having ongoing
relationships to to looking at vaccine
Innovation our vaccines currently are
not good enough we need to improve the
the quality of the vaccines and
durability the ability to stop
transmission the way in which we give
vaccines lots of things that need to be
improved and that's not going to happen
in a vaccine and that in a vacuum and
that's where we need to bring together
the capabilities that we've got working
in Partnership as we did effectively in
2020 to actually make sure we stay ahead
of the game and not constantly looking
in the rear view mirror
before I turn to a couple of colleagues
starting with Stephen Metcalf just one
thing on uh Innovation so the vaccines
manufacturing Innovation Center actually
predated covert I should disclose it was
part of the industrial strategy and it
was an assessment that we made that we
needed to have this capability in
manufacturing and Innovation I think my
reading of what's happened with the vmic
is that the Innovation mandate uh for
for the vmic has been lost has been
deleted is that is that if I understood
that correctly
that is my understanding
um and again it's not we've necessarily
lost people it's not end us and the
skills but we have no there is no
leadership there's no mandate there's no
I in vmic as far as I can see uh has
been eliminated so we've lost the
manufacturing side of it because it's
been mothballed and we've lost the
Innovation side because no one is
actually
continuing that or supporting that so
now if we have Innovative vaccines that
want vaccine companies that want to work
with the UK to develop Next Generation
vaccines I don't know who they talk to
or where they go
well I'm Craig you've spoken very
clearly very powerfully and concisely um
it may be that you've anticipated some
of the questions that my colleagues uh
have but nevertheless I'm ready to go to
Stephen Metcalf thank you yes I mean my
question I think you have uh pretty much
already answered I was going to ask what
are the weaknesses in uh UK capability
to deal with new variants as they emerge
and I think you've sort of already
highlighted some of those is there
anything you would add to
um to to your I suppose you know
thoughts on how we can become better
prepared for new variants as they emerge
but one of the things that we invested
in was um scaling up the assay
capability at portion down for
evaluating new variants and that again I
think has worked well it allows us to
actually evaluate the effectiveness of
vaccines against new variants as they
emerge
um but again there's no as far as I
understand it there is no no leadership
there's no one coordinating this there's
no one working with industry to to
basically work out what we you know what
we could be doing to address these new
variants and and if you look at it I
mean across the industry over 70 of new
discovery new drugs and vaccines being
discovered come from small and
medium-sized Enterprises working closely
with Academia so 70 of the industry is
these small companies and they do need
to be able to work uh with with a with
somebody in government to work out how
they can scale up and evaluate their new
formats and that's not happening at the
moment
now I think across loud and clear and I
think the one thing that will overcome
many of the challenges you've
highlighted is some proper leadership
um so thank you for that that's all I
really need to ask Tom Butler
thank you thank you your
um in the room can I just uh just a
point of clarification do we have the
infrastructure and Manufacturing base to
produce vaccines for a future pandemic
um
broadly when we've got um capability in
the salon gene therapy catapult the the
Essex based Veterinary vaccine plant
that has some capability we've got the
contract development manufacturing
organization so also biomedica Fujifilm
up in Darlington work hard so those are
all independent companies that we helped
scale up their capacity as I said Cobra
is moving a lot of net with its new US
owners moving a lot of the manufacturing
to the us
so we do have
some capability we don't have any
capability to manufacture antibodies
bulk antibodies and so we are dependent
on external exports so we're definitely
better
um but we are
short of of being able to do
um we're short of being able to not
depend on Imports because at the moment
we are dependent on Imports
um for
certainly mRNA vaccines moderna's not
going to get built anytime soon CPI is
the group up in Darlington also that has
has developed a very fine process but
that's a low scale process low volume
process so that we can't scale
population vaccines there
thank you and I think the pandemic
showed us how important it is that we
invest in our own infrastructure so that
we can uh Mass produce to scale and
there was lots of public money invested
in developing the vaccine with Oxford
um and but then when the vaccine was
developed it was offered at different
price points globally and I think that
might have had an impact on the vaccine
rollout in other countries and in a
pandemic you know if it's if if a if a
country has a prevalent uh problem it
then spreads to other countries so you
know we can't sort of vax ourselves
vaccinate ourselves in isolation I'm
just wondering
um what is the global value of having
vaccinations made
um more for with a focus on protection
rather than profit
well just to be clear the AstraZeneca
vaccine was not sold at the profit it
was sold at a non-profit basis uh to
high-income countries and it is a very
discounted basis to low-income countries
so AZ uh GSK sanofi Johnson and Johnson
all worked on non-profit bases so these
major companies full went their profits
they could make if they manufactured
other products in order to provide
vaccines and because of that the AZ
vaccine uh according to the economists
saved more lives in the world than any
other vaccine so I don't think profit
was the motive for those vaccine
companies uh profit was a motive for the
MRNA vaccine companies uh and those
those vaccines were less widely
distributed to the low and middle-income
countries because they were too
expensive and too complex to deliver
with the very significant cold chain
requirements yeah can I just um come
back on that I mean you're absolutely
right AZ was uh developed of course
non-profit but it was still offered at
different price points uh in some
countries
um but but again I just I just want a
bit more clarity from you in terms of I
mean AZ was more popular because it was
offered at a cheaper price point than
yeah is it is that important if we're
ever going to cope with another Global
pandemic is that important that vaccines
are offered as not-for-profit is that an
important method to go forward
in order to to control pandemics we need
to make sure that all those people who
are most vulnerable are vaccinated and
if there is a significant uh cost to get
vaccines the Low Middle income countries
are not going to get those vaccines so
it is critical that everybody who needs
to be vaccinated is vaccinated and done
so in a way that is doable and the AZ is
not a or has not been a vaccine company
yet they managed to stand up license
agreements with manufacturing companies
all around the world to be able to
manufacture their vaccine as you say at
very low costs in some countries and
that is the right thing to do yes thank
you so much thank you very much
and just a final question a couple of
big questions from me Dame Kate
um the world doesn't stand still in
other countries that might not have done
as well originally have looked at our
example and I was struck by what you
said about Europe you said Europe is now
thinking about pandemic preparedness in
a systematic professional and effective
way that put in place a comprehensive
process to explore vaccines of all
modalities with a budget for advanced
purchase agreements capacity
reservations
Etc they engage constructively with
vaccine companies it sounds like they've
studied what you did and copied it is
that would that be inaccurate well
whether they're committed or not they've
done the right thing which is to I mean
they were slow to get off the locks to
begin with but they've now done what
needs to be done which is to recognize
this is not going to be the last
pandemic and we need to have a better
and quicker approach to identifying
potential pathogens and being able to
build vaccines very rapidly against new
variants or new pathogenic of new new
pathogens and they they are doing
exactly what we've recommended that the
UK does it just our approach seems to
have been to go backwards right of them
to continue the momentum we've got a new
prime minister we've got a new
ministerial team your advice to them
would be to
turn the vehicle around instead of going
backwards instead of going the opposite
direction from where you recommends
would it be fair to say it's not too
late to to change course
no I mean
I mean again I think there are some
things that are pretty uh severe I mean
I think vmic is not a good outcome for
us but I would recommend to the to the
new prime minister and ministers to go
ahead and read the recommendation as we
gave in December 2020. those
recommendations haven't changed and uh I
haven't shared them with Europe but
they're certainly following a lot of
them thank you and one final pep sub
technical uh question
um on intellectual property which is
important in developing new drugs and
treatments we're in because in
negotiation to join the trans-pacific
trade agreement the ctpp
the IP regime
in that agreement
um differs from what we have in the UK
now I think it involves a Year's Grace
um for registering patents
um is that a problem is that something
that negotiators need to be aware of to
to preserve our ability to have a
flourishing Life Sciences industry and
get the benefits of that
um yes it is so that anything that puts
us in contravention of the European
packet convention uh would be uh
catastrophic
our companies depend on being able to
protect their their products and
intellectual property using uh using
patterns and uh if we are forced out of
the European
um patent convention uh that will
basically cost our companies uh
significant uh costs and hassle because
we'll have to duplicate
um all of all of that work and the
reality is our companies will just
relocate so they won't be based in the
UK they'll be based in in those areas
where they can actually secure patent
costs and traffic rights at lower costs
so it's there seems to be a potential
for an old own goal and we need to make
sure that um there is an opt-out from on
the on the patent the intellectual
property uh Clauses within this Trade
Agreement otherwise we risk really
harming the biotech sector and our
um patent agent profession which again
punches disregation above its weight
with the the patent work that it does on
behalf of international companies as
well as UK companies but that is a risk
not a certainty so what you're saying is
you you're you you hope and want the
negotiators to to be cognizant of this
and and not do something inadvertently
that could be as you put it catastrophic
uh thank you very much I think there are
no other questions from colleagues you
have been admirably remarkably concise
but at no cost whatsoever to the force
of your evidence so we're very grateful
to you for evidence today uh democate
and for the contribution that you made
to the development and deployment of the
vaccines during the pandemic uh thank
you very much indeed that concludes this
meeting of our joint committee order
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended